we are here today because chris
hemsworth your lead actor showed you
this script how many times has that
happened that an actor has brought the
script to you and not the other way
around occasionally it happens and it
doesn't lead to a movie but Russell
Crowe actually brought me Cinderella Man
and that was a you know he wanted to
play James Braddock and and introduced
me to that story and and this was a
situation where we had finished up rush
we were in post-production and I'd had a
really good experience with kris on rush
and was impressed by you know his
approach to the character his you know
it was a great script by peter morgan
but he but he kept mining it in delving
you know into the into the character and
I felt I felt there was a creative
ambition there that was exciting I mean
looking at your resume of films there's
a handful of actors that you have worked
with so memorably several times whether
it's Michael Keaton or Russell Crowe or
Tom Hanks when do you know when you're
working with someone for the first time
that it's someone you're going to want
to work with again really soon is it
within the first couple meetings is it
once you're on set for a couple days or
is it further down the production after
it's been a while well there boy there
there so many actors that I've worked
that I would love to work with again not
only not only does those guys and and
Chris but oh paul bettany I've worked
with again you know jennifer connelly i
worked with more than more than once I
you know but so many cate blanchett and
i just the list goes on and on gia ma
Paul Giamatti there's there so many but
it get along with most actors and and I
and I you know enjoy the rapport and I'm
and so I'm rarely disappointed and in
almost every instance uh you know in
ninety nine percent of the people that
I've worked with I would jump at a
chance to work with again because you
know I I'm pretty careful in the casting
as I said I've rarely been rarely be
disappointed but you know some some some
actors particularly lead actors you know
they sued um it's kind of an act it's
kind of an X Factor you know they it's
it's not only their what they can bring
to the role it's not only their work
ethic and their attitude around it but
it's also they become a kind of a a good
collaborator and that's why i call you
sometimes refer to them as an X Factor
and and they'll you know they have ideas
that elevate you know everything around
the project and and and you know and
they know how to work with the director
so it's not intrusive in any way it's
just additive so take me back to the
moment where you've decided for sure
that this is the going to be the film
that you're going to take on next when
you have something that is the scale and
scope of something like this I mean
maybe maybe Apollo 13 rivals it as far
as just how much you're biting off
what's the first phone call you make
what's the first department head that
you sit down with to try to figure out
how do what's the first bite that you
take well in this case it was visual
fact because I you know the I had dealt
with um you know Oh virtually every
challenge that I knew I was going to
face in this in this movie I did I you
know I had experienced some some
iteration of it at some point maybe on a
smaller scale maybe a sequence not an
entire movie but whether it was the
water above the water under the water of
the fire you know mechanics in a tank
that sort of thing and of course I've
been around cg I'm you know most of my
career but this is the first time there
would be a character and so I went to
Jody Johnson who had been the VFX
supervisor of from for double negative
on on Rush and you know we had a lot of
real formula 1 cars in rush and we had a
few replicas that we built but you even
I could no longer look at the screen and
tell you how many CGI
as we had added in to flush out the
field and and they were so authentic
Jody had achieved that and he'd achieved
that efficiently cost-effectively
creatively and I went to him and I said
well I've seen life of pi I've seen the
latest Planet of the Apes you know I
have a feeling this is possible what's
entailed can we ever you know afford it
look how much there is to be done and
and so that was the for any assured me
that we could I mean after after really
analyzing it and did a great job we will
one interesting thing that I'd never
experienced you know we we storyboarded
we did animatics they they weren't there
wasn't much finish on those animatics
because I didn't want to invest the
money in in that but the sequences were
built around these these things we you
know I went out into the water or the
tank or wherever it was taking place
shot everything edited them together
using the storyboards and the animatics
and had a pretty good sense of what you
know how the scene was flowing feeling
pretty good about it but when we started
to get the final whale shots in there
was just something a little off not
about the the scenes and we actually had
to go back and read it because suddenly
there was a real character and it just
changed the rhythms and it changed you
know we needed to modify some of the
reactions of the actors things think it
were different is a recut because now we
actually had a whale does it give you
peace of mind my understanding is that
the life of pi first ad was the first ad
here will you like get me that guy
whoever he is I've never met him before
but I need him well I i I'd worked with
him over a period of 20 years so I you
know I just it was you know he'd been my
first ad on a number of movies already
and had had done that one in between
okay pictures and so it was a great was
a great coincidence not only did did he
have that tank experience he didn't have
very much experience out on the real
water and for budgetary reasons and also
for the authenticity I wanted to shoot
as much as we could in
the actual ocean I knew it would save us
money but moreover you know I felt like
that you know authenticity was a
watchword for me on this and I and I
wanted I one of the actors to have that
connection with the environment I wanted
us to be forced into that I wanted us to
have to shoot with the sort of immediacy
and intimacy that that would force us to
do and he was a pretty leery about that
but you know the budget kind of forced
forced us into it anyway but it was it
was it was fine you know we wound up
doing you know only scenes that were had
involved stunts on you know anything
dangerous and we use the tank everything
else the Canary Islands you know that
seems really counterintuitive to me i
would think that it'd be cheaper to film
in an enclosed tank instead of out on
the open ocean is because you're just
not paying a location fee I mean what's
the reason that is cheaper to film in
the real ocean CGI blades you know just
filling in the background and it's just
that you know if you're suddenly you're
into hundreds and hundreds of more shots
and so sometimes that's a valid
trade-off because you know it's
difficult to control the weather and the
timing and so forth but I I just kind of
pledge to shoot this in a very
naturalistic sort of almost you know doc
you style in a way and and and we we had
contingency plan upon contingency plan
and the actors were really prepared
within the time frame because we were
shooting in sequence so that they could
lose the weight and and and and and and
following them the storyline but with
within that the actors understood that
we would we would shift according to the
weather in order to keep shooting and so
if they had to move out of one emotional
scene and into another one because you
know the light had changed significantly
or the weather had we we would do that
we didn't have to do too much of it but
in a number of occasions we did and they
were they were unbelievable they were
ready to roll with it I would imagine
that in casting a movie like this where
the dumb
hands are so physically strenuous for
your actors that you're looking at not
only their skill and are they right for
each part but do they have the metal do
they have what's inside to be a good
teammate for you and to handle all of
this how did you know in meeting with
actors what questions did you ask them
to ensure that they would be right for
it and write for the demands once you
were filming it well you can't know you
know for certain I did know Chris would
would have it I mean he'd you you you
wouldn't know it but he had to lose a
lot of weight for I mean if you think
about he would he had to lose a lot of
weight just to be James Hunt just to be
able to get in an f1 car from forsyth or
yeah and and and he had done that and
also that movie was done very quickly
difficult conditions the weather wasn't
always with us and it's is that he just
had a you know tremendous attitude about
it so I knew I knew that would be there
you know you're meeting the actors and
you and you you you say it you confront
it you say here's going to be the
expectation you can imagine how
difficult that's going to be you know
there's going to be physical training
there's going to be diet there's you
know and it's it's it's not going to be
pleasant and and and you know you sort
of bring it up once you reinforce it
with the agent you mentioned it one more
time before you know in a phone call
back before before you cast them and
then and then rehearsal when a few of
them start to drift you say remember
that conversation we had I meant that
and and and so you know I did I did have
to be a little firm or early on but
people fell into it and you know I think
there's an added advantage when you're
when when actors are playing real
characters because you know they wanted
to to respect the memory of the people
they were playing even if they're just
you know thumbnail sketches of who the
men were the and when I would ask them
or mentioned to them or acknowledged
just how much they were in how much they
were suffering to try to get this right
and I appreciated it they would say well
it's just you know it's just a fraction
of what the guy that I was playing it
had gone through so and and they
you know they just wanted to approach it
with integrity and offer that to
audiences